caitlyn jenner is
running for office the 71 year old
former olympian announced that she has
filed paperwork to run for california
governor in 2022
i'm looking forward to it we've got a
lot of things going on jenner shared the
news on twitter
saying i'm in california is worth
fighting for
and the former reality star already has
an official campaign website
so much has happened in my life a
statement posted by jenner on the
site says quote california has been my
home for nearly 50 years
i came here because i knew that anyone
regardless of their background or
station in life
could turn their dreams into reality now
what does her famous family think about
her run for governor
a source tells et caitlyn running for
california governor is not a big
surprise to the kardashians and jenners
quote caitlyn has been vocal about
wanting to get involved in politics for
quite some time now while the family may
not be entirely aligned politically
speaking
they ultimately want caitlyn to be happy
and fulfilled
everybody goes through tough times in
their life and deals with a lot of
different things
i always look at it as everybody has
their stuff
you know and it's how you deal with your
stuff and how you come out the other end
jenner has been a big advocate of equal
rights for the lgbtq plus community
since coming out as transgender back in
2015.
and last year she opened up to e.t about
the importance of politics and the trans
community
you know from the trans community
politics unfortunately is important
we talk about equality and equal rights
for everybody
um uh for the last year i haven't done
that much
um kind of waiting to see once this
election's over with
uh and what we can do so um
there may be some but probably not a lot
until
something is really important i have a
platform that i can
put it out there which is nice although
jenner has been vocal about her
political opinions in the past
back in october while appearing on the
carlos watson show
she revealed why she initially took a
step back from politics
at first i really tried hard politically
to make a difference
started my own foundation and i just
as time went on i just kind of got more
and more disappointed
because i was hammered because i've
always been more on the republican side
than i have the democrats
it came to the point where i just said i
got back out of it
and i never felt like i deserved it but
you know
everybody makes mistakes and you just
try to do the best job you possibly can
that's all you can do
if jenner were to win she would not be
the first celebrity to serve as governor
of california
i'll be back action star arnold
schwarzenegger famously took on the role
from 2003
to 2011 and e.t was with the actor
during his political campaign
everything's great yes positive campaign
it's terrific
you'll be having a good time you know
the people the amount of crowds like i
said it's getting bigger and bigger and
bigger
so there's a great movement here and
there's people all here not because of
me i think they're here because of hope
[Music]